you know why they say the time is the
greatest magician because it's just an
illusion hello and welcome to Friday
hurry I will be your person holding the
camera poorly grace Helbig you guys
don't know friary is my vlog looking
back at my week so let's look back at
the week shall we we started the week by
ending electro one and Dyna girl hello
it is Sunday afternoons literally
afternoon
12:28 p.m. it is my last full day in
Canada I leave tomorrow after I finish
up my scenes the glass scenes I have for
electro man and Dyna girl it's um it's
kind of a gray day feels a little lonely
today and I'm treating myself because I
just went to the grocery store to get
food and I'm in one of those moods where
I just want to eat everything all the
time so I got all the things I got half
a little chicken some grocery store
sushi always the best and some beef stew
in there so very Canadian and I haven't
washed my hair for three days thank you
okay so the Sunday has developed Hannah
and I took a trip to Michael's and we
might have overindulged in some craft
supplies
time to craft good morning guys it's
Monday my last day man Coover piebald
ahead to set all my bags are packed I'm
saying goodbye to the hotel room goodbye
hotel room felt good by that building
that I looked at a lot
goodbye tiny metal birds that serve no
purpose let's cleanse before we go did
it somebody dancing like no one's
watching over there here's our on set
I'm in my room now it's the last day I
just got hair makeup done
I'm not in the first couple scenes that
I've rolling to set without me but
everyone's been so sweet and so nice and
last day and giving each other gifts and
I got all kinds of snacks in there
there's some underwear that I'm not
wearing nothing not wearing underwear
I'm just wearing my own in the work
today
the glamour and Hannah and I made a
bunch of gifts that we are going to give
out throughout the day and then I go to
the airport and I get on the plane and I
go back to Los Angeles was just gonna be
so strange I haven't been there in five
weeks
she's doing acting walking this is Megan
Megan what's your last name
McKinnon Megan McKenna and drop by site
today and she just happens to be Miss
Teen Canada and look what she just got
that that look at my even holding it
right like look at that sign I'm gonna
try this on wait can you help me on you
okay oh my god oh my god it's happening
to me each chick saundra Pollock it's
beautiful beautiful in front of this
weird gross alcove in front of a
money-hungry casino Megan so wendice
internationals and Peter's here you're
really pretty
Peter was the judge I really liked your
talent my talent for eating chips for
breakfast Jim yeah there are Meghan
when's the international tournament it's
in July in Virginia Beach okay so make
sure you cheer on Meghan okay and now
I'm gonna give you this crown back
before I heard it's okay I can't I can't
take care of nice things
Sam the heart just wrapped it's a wrap
on it and uh yeah uh you shut up because
we are so small that Brett's other job
that he left us for is shooting directly
next to us believe I can fly
kind of saying goodbye to everyone so
sweet sweet sweet this is forgettable
good morning everyone I'm back in Los
Angeles and I'm driving it is Tuesday
morning and I am headed to the house
that we are shooting the grace Helbig
show out of I was so excited we rented a
house so that it feels a lot like my
videos that it all takes place in a home
so everyone that doesn't want to go out
on a Friday night at 10:30 can stay
inside with me so we're gonna go see the
house and see the team people that have
already been working on the show let's
do it
[Music]
how about this thing you might never
remember I've reached a new level I'm
going to a meeting straight out of the
shower without my hair dry yeah we were
headed to the house
the graceshow house I guess is what I'll
be calling it for clarity purposes James
who is the production designer who is
making the house of beautiful and cool
and interesting and way better bleed
dress than I could do it it's coming
over and we're gonna walk through all
the ideas her front door this is the
front door so this is all I filmed Oh
guys I've been cleaning for hours and
look I just showed up Oh could you even
see that blur and she's out yeah she
gets so excited as soon as she gets here
she's got to take a massive Shh
yay now two freaks in this house we're
just gonna stake out because when goose
takes a [ __ ] and she comes back in the
house she comes in like a wrecking ball
so let's see how has she been inspired
by me and girl too because it seems like
a huge dump 20 pounds later good job
what about this fleeting moment of time
a local morning it is Thursday and I've
gone with this hairstyle today we are
headed to the YouTube space to have some
meetings and the YouTube space is always
a great time because you never know
who's gonna be there there's always a
variety of interesting shenanigan makers
abundant at the YouTube
so let's see what we find I switched my
sunglasses big day guys big day but they
did give me lamb meatballs for lunch so
Google my name okay okay
nope I don't want to call someone you
can also say call plus the name of the
contact cancel
yeah life lesson always be direct sorry
I didn't really poor job filming
anything at the YouTube space so let's
imagine this is what it was like wow
Julie go away this is just how Wendy
does my hair when there's a tie rid of
these we put on so you can clean it up
as you guys can see where the process of
lightening up the hair recoloring it
this one just wants to be part of it you
get in highlights nope
good try good try sucka here's something
that kept me preoccupied from thinking
about that it's a wild name down we're
shooting some opening credits for a USA
Greg is over there okay Greg what's your
official title executive producer hey
USA something like that what one of
those fancy fancy schmancy and look now
oh there's a light behind you otherwise
I'd be like people can Photoshop you
into all sorts of terrible things
they're gonna Oh
guess who made a Friday night Michaels
run I did you see it's all in the basket
I got that basket 40% off yeah Michaels
what a guy and this is how I feel about
it
[Music]
[Applause]
gjf what'd I say
TGIF TGIF crap bingo there's a look back
this evening
they go guys there's a look back at my
week also quick tech tip for you pros
out there don't need to buy fancy camera
carrying bags you can put socks on your
camera look at that always wrap it up
like this video I don't know guys I'm oh
I don't need to yell get out of here I
want to let you guys know that I am
selling sweatshirts on represent calm
and their sweatshirt to say dressed to
repress and I'm really really excited
about them goose how excited are you
about them and you're gone look like
this wow wow and there's not much time
left in the campaign so if you are
interested in that sweatshirt design
please go take a look at it represent
comm slash it's grace for the number
four and there's a bunch of really great
colors and honestly I have to say this
design is the one that I really really
want it would be mad if I didn't design
this myself and I want all the colors
that are available okay gotta go check
it out